wir können jetzt fragen stellen zu
diesem thema an mikro hutaree er ist der
direktor des mercator mehr cato
institute für china studieren schönen
guten abend
wieso ist denn taiwan etwas was china so
sehr provoziert was an dem leben was an
der lebensart vielleicht was was ist es
was china da so trade und warum ist das
also so lange schon ein konfliktthema
um die führung in peking ist da relativ
klar das ist ein teil chinas das ist
eine abtrünnige provinz die seit
jahrzehnten sozusagen in einem status
vor sich hin manövriert den peking
niemals toleriert hat und es ist eine
der zentralen konflikte in der
peripherie wie hongkong im bett
aufstehen dann aufgeladen
sehr stark politisch da geht es um die
vision chinas als großmacht aufzutreten
und die eigene territoriale integrität
sowie das formulierten natürlich um
jeden preis zu schützen und der ging
wird hier hinter die gezogene rote linie
keinen schritt zurücktreten und da
natürlich in der letzten zeit größere
selbstbewusstsein gefasst und fühlt sich
in der stärkeren position es ist ja
nicht das erste mal dass wir einen
konflikt in der taiwanstraße haben aber
die militärischen bedingungen die stärke
und machtverhältnisse haben sich
natürlich in den letzten 20 jahren
deutlich verschoben und peking sieht
sich hier in der lage jetzt auch die
eigene stärke zu demonstrieren
china hat sich auch jetzt schon dazu
geäußert zu diesem besuch eben ein video
veröffentlicht auch im vorfeld eben um
die militärische stärke zu zeigen es war
heute die rede von gezielten
militärischen aktionen die jetzt folgen
sollen was hat das alles zu bedeuten wie
würden sie das einschätzen ist china da
im ernstfall wirklich dazu bereit
wir sollten keinen zweifel daran haben
dass mittelfristig langfristig china
klar die intention hat
sich wieder einzuverleiben als teil der
volksrepublik in welcher form auch immer
ob das friedlich geschieht oder
militärisch rhetorisch sagt man
weiterhin das muss friedlich geschehen
aber es ist natürlich jetzt ein
risikopotenzial in der region statt
angewachsen der militärische kräfte sind
zusammengezogen auf allen seiten weibern
mobilisiert durchaus
amerikanische kräfte in der region das
birgt das risiko von einer
ungewollten letztlich eskalation wir
müssen uns auch darüber im klaren sein
dass moment beide seiten ihre macht
demonstrieren und säbelrasseln betreiben
nach unserer ansicht ist es nicht so
dass wir hier unmittelbar mit einer
kriegerischen auseinandersetzung rechnen
sollten aber es ist eben eine situation
wo keiner einen schritt zurücktritt und
in so einer spiraldynamik kann natürlich
einiges passieren und jetzt ist nancy
pelosi ja nicht die us präsidentin sie
ist die vorsitzende des
repräsentantenhauses aber wieso wird das
jetzt auch schon als ein so provokanter
besuch gesehen von seiten chinas
nun formal ist sie natürlich die
dritthöchste repräsentantin des staates
und insofern fühlt sich die führung in
peking müßig zu sagen das ist ein
staatsbesuch
umgekehrt schon die amerikanische seite
es ist in einer tradition von kongress
besuchen dann sind das natürlich
interpretations fragen letztlich geht es
darum dass sich in den letzten jahren
auf allen seiten sozusagen schritte
angedeutet haben die eben weniger
kompromissfähigkeit zeigen auf seiten
der usa ist dass immer weniger seine
politik der
unklarheit die man gegenüber taiwan und
china dort vertritt also eine klare
commitments ein bestätigung auch der
unterstützung taiwans auf der seite
china seit vielen jahren wurde der druck
erhöht militärisch wirtschaftspolitisch
im internationalen raum und auch auf
seiten teil er ist natürlich die führung
derzeit bemüht sich klar zu machen das
ist hier keinesfalls kompromisse geben
kann mit blick auf die frage wie peking
hier seine eigenen interessen durchsetzt
kann also ich glaube alle seiten sind
wir gut beraten einen schritt
zurückzutreten aber letztlich ist klar
die volksrepublik dreht hier an der
spirale die amerikaner versuchen hier
insbesondere auf der kongress seite ein
starkes zeichen zu setzen dass die
unterstützung für treiber da ist und
auch immer da bleiben wird
wir müssen vielleicht auch noch mal ganz
grundsätzlich auch was klären es gibt
hier nämlich eine frage bei youtube von
bach erfragt deutschland hat japan noch
nicht als eigenständiges land anerkannt
oder und das gilt ja auch für viele
andere länder auch für die usa
vielleicht könnten sie uns hier noch mal
ein bisschen hintergrundinformationen
geben wieder der status quo ist es ist
richtig staaten haben die anerkennung
teil 1 gewechselt zur volksrepublik
china
1972 die 50 jahre deutsch chinesische
beziehungen mit der volksrepublik stehen
anders ab jahren hintergrund vorher
wurde da zumindest von einigen staaten
teilnahmen anerkannt also in der tat
kein europäischer staat auch nicht die
usa das wurde jetzt zuletzt auch noch
mal von der administration bestätigt es
gibt jetzt nicht darum dass die
unabhängigkeit taiwans hier sozusagen
erreicht werden soll es geht um den
status quo und der status quo bedeutet
eben das ist eine gewisse unklarheit mit
blick auf die zukunft die nur treibern
und auch und die taiwanische bevölkerung
mitbestimmen darf und insofern
militärische und sicherheitspolitische
verschiebung der lage oder der versuch
eben hier einseitig eine veränderung
herbeizuführen durch druck insbesondere
auf seiten der volksrepublik ist etwas
was nicht toleriert werden
ein thema was viele hier auch in den
kommentaren interessiert ich komme auch
gleich zu den fragen dazu ist das teil
aber tatsächlich trotz seiner größe das
ist ja sehr sehr klein aber
wirtschaftlich enorme auswirkungen hat
denn experten und expertinnen experten
gehen außerdem davon aus dass wenn es
dort zu einer militärischen eskalation
kommen sollte dass eben größere
auswirkungen haben könnte als jetzt
gerade der russische krieg in der
ukraine allein schon auf uns alle hat
wir haben dazu auch mal ein paar fakten
zusammengetragen das ist wichtig zu
wissen china ist mit einem anteil weil
das wäre ja auch ein konflikt partner
von rund 11,8 prozent an den
gesamtimporten deutschlands damit ist es
größter import partner eben und zum
vergleich taiwan liegt mit gut einem
prozent zwar auf platz 25 aber eben
dieses kleine land hat eine große
bedeutung denn es ist unser wichtiger
exportpartner für die chip produktion
und das bringt mich dazu dass einige von
euch sich auch genau diese frage stellen
hat ein konflikt dort eben auch eine
eskalation dort auswirkungen auf uns zum
beispiel oliver möchte bei youtube
wissen deutsche investitionen in china
die steigen immer mehr falls es eine
krise zwischen china und taiwan geben
sollte wohin geht diese situation wie
geht die reise dann weiter haben sie da
antworten für oliver rong und andere
und erstmal jetzt klar dass die politik
zunehmend damit ich meine ich die
deutsche und die europäische politik
signale sende wie sie mit so einer krise
umgehen würde wenn sie dann militärisch
eskaliert von seiten der volksrepublik
betrieben die aussenministerin hatte
gesagt auch der europäische außen-
vertreter haben signalisiert dass wir
dann in einen see sanktions szenario
auslaufen würden und habe parallelen
gezogen zu den europäischen sanktionen
gegenüber russland aufgrund des angriffs
links in der ukraine und das hätte
dramatische auswirkungen für die
deutsche und europäische volkswirtschaft
in der tat müssten viele unternehmen
sich dann überlegen haben ob sie weiter
in china produzieren operieren können
und da die deutschland insbesondere so
verflochten ist mit der volksrepublik
hätte das durchaus sehr direkt und weit
reichende folgen für die deutsche
volkswirtschaft haben sie denn
vielleicht können sie das mal für uns
einordnen was sehen sie jetzt gerade als
die größeren betrogen oder was hat das
für kurzfristige konsequenzen dieser
besuch jetzt was kann es für welche
haben was hat es aber vielleicht auch
für mittelfristige konsequenzen dazu
passt nämlich auch die frage von annika
die hat per mail geschrieben ich möchte
wissen welche rolle der konflikt im
südchinesischen meer bei dem konflikt um
taiwan spielt dieser betrifft ja noch
deutlich mehr länder in der region aber
vielleicht trennen wir es zuerst so
vielleicht zunächst einmal kurzfristige
mittelfristige konsequenzen was könnte
das bedeuten
kurzfristig ist klar es geht erstmal
darum dass die chinesische seite
angekündigt dass jetzt so genannte live
ein exercises um die insel herum
durchzuführen da geht es darum zu prüfen
ob die sagen historisch angelegt sind
ich gehe davon aus dass einige grenzen
überschritten werden also die gebiete wo
die stattfinden sollen ihm sehr nahe an
der insel taiwan dran wir hatten 1996
auch raketenabschüsse über taiwan alle
solche dinge wenn sie passieren würden
wieder wäre ein klares zeichen dass
peking hier mit aller macht seine stärke
demonstrieren will und dann wird zu
beobachten sein dass man erst mal wieder
sozusagen g eskaliert hoffentlich aus
dieser krise heraus dass alle seiten
einen weg zurück könnten
das jetzt nicht als einen dauerhaften
zustand zu halten ist bescheint offene
kanäle auf allen seiten zu geben das
telefonat zwischen team und arbeiten
weil wir denn joe biden in den usa ist
auch deshalb so wichtig gewesen in den
letzten wochen
und das ist die kurzfristige lage dürfe
nicht vergessen auch in peking ist
gerade eine besondere politische zeit im
august finden häufig führungstreffen
stadt die play der volksbefreiungsarmee
hat da ein wichtiges jubiläum zu feiern
höchst angespannte lage vor dem
zwanzigsten parteikongress ende dieses
jahres im oktober voraussichtlich also
politisch sensibel da gilt das jetzt
erstmal die spannung wieder runter zu
fangen mittelfristig ist klar und das
ist vielleicht das was am meisten uns
herausfordern wird die spannungen
zwischen den usa und china werden sich
verschärfen es gibt hier keinerlei
anzeichen dass beide seiten von ihren
positionen zurücktreten würden und
insofern müssen wir damit rechnen dass
nicht nur solche besucher vielleicht
regelmäßiger stattfinden sondern auch
dass der militärische druck und der
wirtschaftspolitische druck auf thailand
von seiten der volksrepublik dramatisch
hochgefahren werden wird und da wir sie
als china experten jetzt auch gerade bei
uns haben dann auch eben gerne noch die
ihr von mir eben schon angesprochene
frage von annika per mail die fragte
sich eben der konflikt im
südchinesischen meer da geht es ja um
kämpfer um fischer gründe fischerei
gründe öl gas reserven wie der sich noch
weiterentwickeln könnte sie schrieb
zurecht dieser betrifft ja noch deutlich
mehr länder in der region
in diesem konflikt arenen sind durchaus
miteinander verknüpft nicht zuletzt auch
teilweise ansprüche erhebt auch einige
dieser inseln in der region am man hat
auch jetzt gesehen schon die flugroute
von nancy pelosi in ganz absichtlich
natürlich um dieses südchinesischen meer
herum weil dort in den letzten jahren
china durchaus kapazitäten aufgebaut hat
auch militärisch
flüge zu verfolgen oder auch
abwehrraketen zu positionen also eine
verschränkung dieser konflikte liegt auf
der hand alles das was in der region
passiert hat unmittelbare auswirkungen
auch auf die frage wie sich zukünftig
als demokratie in der region halten kann
danke für ihre einschätzung heute abend
ein micro foot ari von mercator institut
für china studies dankeschön